what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here and it's John Humphrey here Thor
Ragan on my Knox is coming out in
November it is not the infinity war
trailer that I'm sure every comment here
is saying the International trailer
number three otherwise known as the
China trailer you need to China trailer
got it got to do it cuz that's what
movies are made for now China do like
China I love China I visit twice a year
make a lot of things that I use regular
and they're the reason we get
consistently great movies
all those box office dollars making sure
that we get more transformers movie the
dark universe continues oh definitely
yeah can't wait for all those sequels
hey it's Thor Ragnarok I'm excited
either way to all the fans in China I'm
sure you already know that China Studios
Thor Ragnarok is confirmed and will be
released in China
don't forget to watch more eggnog when
it comes to a city near you
it's confirmed what does that mean well
sometimes there's issues with like
what's a good this is a great changes
your age
[Music]
as soon as diet plans for you my friend
I have diet plans for destiny
[Music]
be glad
yeah he's dead
need a stopper here now to write the
work and do everything
the other team
interesting booth
he's a fighter
[Music]
Oh
and in death
[Music]
it's called Thor 3:3 picked up on that
as ice I can read Chinese the letters
are different well I was in Colorado you
saw an international trailer yeah I
actually haven't seen that international
trip Oliver was dr. Strange's in that
sure it was a lot like this trace it is
yeah yeah they're like at least for my
viewing experience of this like there
are a couple shots like when he crests
over that thing that I didn't quite
recognize her horns folding up and there
are a couple like longer reverse shots
and things in that Rainbow Bridge fight
yeah the Rainbow Bridge but you see I
felt that this trailer gave us a lot
more of hella versing Thor yeah which I
appreciate a lot because a lot of the
time you know villain giving speeches we
see that yeah even in Marvel movies we
do this seem to emphasize a little bit
more of the one-on-one battles yeah the
actual stakes of the oh my
she's here to destroy yeah because you
had Thor versing hella and the Rainbow
Bridge whatever the actual name is sorry
Valkyrie you get a little bit more of
her and they're even taking on hella as
well what's it called circle search her
the big old demon dude you finally get
to see him in profile that was a really
cool shot too voiced by mr. krabs him so
I feel like we're gonna get a lot of
really awesome fight scenes the number
one thing is getting me anxious about
this whole Thor experience has nothing
to do with Thor it's the damn infinity
war true I heard the infinity war
trailer from a Twitter account that
everyone's like saying hey this person
to Marvel news or whatever said infinity
war trailer will be dropping tomorrow
but everyone's like a lot of people are
saying well most likely it'll probably
be like the post credit scene of Thor
kind of like how Captain America's post
credit scene was the Avengers trailer
people are thinking that's what it'll be
or I'll play before then I'm feeling
anxious because whenever a huge trailer
like that drops I have to be in here all
day
and I have a friend show to go to
tomorrow night and people are like
saying in my premiere during Inhumans
which is around the same time inhuman I
was gonna say like premiering this
trailer during Thor Ragnarok seems like
a great way to make sure the PIO and see
cuz it is like the biggest trade
of anything marvel yet it seems like
yeah however with how terribly the
Inhumans seems to be doing I can see why
they would why they would do it to try
to get it more rating so more people
will tune in at least is one episode
yeah my excitement is kind of distress
I'm still excited for it we already
bought tickets for it you getting
fatigued Greg you getting fatigued yeah
don't die on me man are you marketing
fatigue this is what I'm feeling I feel
that especially now that we have you
know computers in our pockets it's every
it's everywhere you look going back to
this specific trailer for me like
they're a couple of new images but this
is you know it's an international
trailer so it's more action-oriented
the last trailer I saw was about the
battle and this seems equally about the
battle maybe with like you said a higher
emphasis on Thor versus hello what I
really appreciate and I feel like Marvel
is really good at doing this is having
consistency with their trailers I rarely
feel like these are like two entirely
different movies we're looking at it
when you see the trail and yeah it's
weird when the posters come out so weird
they've really throw yeah has a good
poster and the trailers for Thor
Ragnarok have been so consistent in tone
and style and vibe and it's very
different from the last two installments
that Thor
it keeps me excited they're too funny
I'm not worried at all about this movie
I'm really not it's it's that rare like
big movie where I'm like yeah hundred
percent sure I'm gonna like it yeah I'm
only yeah I'm only worried insofar as
like I would like for Thor to have the
one that actually nails it you know cuz
the first Thor is this movie that most
people like like but don't love in the
second movie people and that's what I
worry about I guess because it is kind
of a risk they did get an oddball for
this movie which I'm excited about it
well dude you know they freaking got the
director a barbershop to do Fantastic
Four yeah they did and that was the best
one in miles teller
[Laughter]
just a lot of wrong facts tonight
Jessica Alba Roger Corman it's crazy how
you know Chris Pine sorry as is Thor his
Thor and as Captain America and he's
starring in Jurassic world - it's crazy
how does he keep up with also star-lord
how are they gonna cross over I don't
know
well well it was a worthwhile video
subscribe to the real rejects we're a
little excited click the notification
bell if you'd like I am dad John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram that
is so annoying
you're always repeating me what what oh
you're gonna take it personal now it's
trying to make it fun [ __ ] it's all
that part is not a person no I'm just
never gonna do that again
I'm be like Andrew Andrew it doesn't
bother me I think it's funny and more
engaging